اتمنى المغرب اكيد بدي توقع المجتمني
واحد فرنسي
المباراه صلاح بتكون جدا جدا قويه
والفوز المغرب سيحقق الفوز
وسيصل الى
النهائيين يعني راح نشجعوا المغرب اكثر من
المغرب من المغرب نفسه فرنسا اصعب من
البرتغال ولا البرتغال كانت اصعب من
البرتغالي
وبعدين المنتخب
مرهق بدنيا على الاشواط الاضافيه للاعف
المباراه التوهل وعلى مجود اللي بدل في
السلطاني ضد مباراه البرتغال ولكن ان شاء
الله نقول ولك فرنسا جايه من مر ساعه يعني
فائز فوزين اربعه واحد ثلاثه اربعه ثلاثه
واحد بولندا صح وعندك اثنين واحد انجلترا
فوز مريح يعني ما في اسوان اضافي ما في
شيء
في البطوله الارجنتينيه الان فرنسا بيني
وبينك عندهم لعيبه كويسين يعني
عندهم مدرب صح الارجنتين ترى مدربه مثل
البرازيل مع الاساتذه المغرب والارجنتين
على النهائي
الراس شوف الراس ايش اللي فوق انا المغرب
تحت قلبي اوكي مارجتين بس راسي وان شاء
الله اللي يحرفوا الراس زياده هم ان شاء
الله اسود
[موسيقى]
اثنين واحد ان شاء الله
ولكن ان شاء الله ما تكون نتيجه كبيره ان
شاء الله
توقعات يعني توقعي اثنين واحد منتخب
السعوديه
احنا نوقف مع المغرب ان شاء الله
للمباراه بكره بين المغرب
هتفوز مع الاسف يعني ولكن الامنيه ان شاء
الله من عند الله انه المغرب تفوز بس
اعملها مفاجاه زي معاملات السعوديه مع
الارجنتين
فرنسا
[موسيقى]
وانا حزين يعني وقعتني ان شاء الله الى
المغرب 2-1 وان شاء الله فوز ان شاء الله
باذن الله ان شاء الله اتوقع المغرب ان
شاء الله 3-0 باذن الله 3-0 متفائل ما
يحتاج المال المغرب 100% ما يحتاج
دائما حاله من التخوف من كيليان مبابي
ولكن كذلك اشرف حكيمي يعني زميله واليوم
وليد القراقي قال انه يعني هم على درايبي
بعض اكثر متخوف من امبابه بكره المنتخب
همم نسمي راس الافوكا تحيه لوليد الركراكي
اظن ان نسربحه همم سنربح مباراه عن طريق
ضربه الترجيح همم ستكون كما قلت مباراه
التكتيكيه تعطيني توقعك لمباراه فرنسا
للمغرب اتوقع اثنين واحد المغرب ان شاء
الله المغرب
كل تحليله كان ضد المغرب بعدين توقع اثنين
واحد لا مو ضد المغرب
صراحه نار راح اسجل بكره المنتخب ما يهمش
المنتخب الوطني المغربي كل الافراد دياله
كلهم كتله واحده سواء حقه زياش او حكيمي
او امرابط او بونو علاش لا المهم ديال
المنتخب المغربي اليوم
[موسيقى]